To explore these various input methods,
we'll use the same test bed throughout
this lesson, which is based on
the screen saver we built last level.
Now, instead of the ball just
moving in a straight line forever,
we'll control its movement with key
presses, touches, and the accelerometer.
Let's explore the test bed a bit.
First, our application listener
is called InputTestBed, and
it extends Game.
The only thing we have to do in
this file is set the game screen,
which we set to a new
instance of BallScreen.
Let's check that out next.
BallScreen is responsible for setting up
a place to draw, and then delegates all
the logic about what the ball actually
does to this BouncingBall class.
BallScreen extends ScreenAdapter
which is a convenient implementation
of the screen interface.
ScreenAdapter provides
blank implementations of
all the screens required methods,
which means we can just override
the ones that we're interested in.
There's a few new things here, the first
of which is this AutoShapeType.
When ShapeRenderer is
in AutoShapeType mode,
that means we can change shape
types in the middle of a batch.
This is incredibly convenient
when you are passing
your shape render into other
objects to use for drawing.
Note we use an extend viewport to make
the shortest access of the world equal
to WORLD_SIZE.
Also note that every time the window
is resized, we just reset the ball.
Then down here in render,
we do all the normal stuff.
Applying the viewport, clearing the
screen, setting the ProjectionMatrix.
Then we tell the ball to update itself,
we start a shape renderer batch, and
we tell the ball to go ahead and
draw itself using our shape renderer.
Let's check out what the ball is doing.
So this BouncingBall class is quite long
and I encourage you to just open up this
demo in the course code and
check it out for yourself.
The behavior of this ball should
be pretty familiar from the screen
saver example.
There are two new things, drag and
the periodic kicks that the ball
receives to show off that drag.
Down here in update If its been
sufficiently long since we last gave
the ball a kick, then we go ahead and
give the ball a new kick.
And here is where we apply drag.
Every frame the velocity is
reduced by an amount proportional
to the current velocity.
Let's see this all in action.
So, we see we've got a little red
ball that occasionally gets kicked in
a random direction.
Then, it slowly comes to a stop.
It kind of looks like an air
hockey table, and if we resize it,
it just resets itself to the middle.
All right, so this is fun,
but it's not interactive yet.
Well, let's fix that.